[Musique]
face à l'explosion du nombre de
contaminations le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines a ouvert le 10
janvier dernier une zone de dépistage
500 tests antigénique par jour là et 10
bloqué pour un bras de fer le cirque
zavatta douchez a stoppé la circulation
pour obtenir une installation après une
réunion avec le préfet les yvelines il a
obtenu gain de cause ce sera sur l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
il aurait lire à saint cyr l'école
assange armand les les premières rames
du tram 13 ont commencé à circuler pour
les tests la mise en service est prévue
à l'été 2000 22 c'est une première dans
les yvelines la ville de carrières sous
poissy s'est vu remettre le label villes
engagées contre le sida un moyen de
rendre plus visible à lui des
collectivités contre le vih une
enseignante de sciences de collège de
trappes exfiltré de son établissement du
département la raison un cours sur
l'évolution de la boue elle avait montré
une photo du chanteur soprano un cours
ayant entraîné des menaces sur les
réseaux sociaux la décision date de
novembre à date de l'audience on appelle
n'est pas encore fixée des absences
d'enseignants surveillants et de
personnels administratifs à cause de
lakovic 19 face à cette situation
l'académie de versailles compte
embaucher 500 personnes parmi les
retraités de l'éducation nationale et
des jeunes diplômés
[Musique]